raymond raconte le téléspectateur tu as
été convoqué pour je reçois un coup de
fil c'était bonjour sept commissariats
est-ce que vous pouvez venir dans nos
locaux
soir suite à une enquête judiciaire qui
a été ouvert à votre encontre là je ne
peux pas venir tout de suite parce que
je travaille mais demain si vous voulez
juin demain et donc j'y vais demain j'y
vais le lendemain donc il ya ben je vais
dans les locaux tout se passe bien
quelle entité je mente au première étage
échoué auditionné pour une histoire de
carreaux cassés c'était une grande
vitrine dans un immeuble qui appartient
à une mairie parce que maintenant quand
tu passes à la télé les gens qui t'ont
vu donc les jeunes moussanais
l'abruti tu dis moi oui mais j'ai pas
fait exprès trois salles un
carreau trois ou quatre radios voilà 400
mal de carreaux donc j'aimerais bien
qu'en plein air et à aimer gauche et
avec non plus ma mère négocie pas assez
à s'enlacer fermer la halle au pjd parti
ils finissent à 17 ans
tu fais agresser on sait casse